I actually do yeah could you tell
yeah yeah okay excuse me have you
cleaned Beth's Rigby seat oh yeah she
wants to be
Mr Emery here we go there you go you sit
there I'll be your I'll be the opposing
manager
I wouldn't if I was a manager though I
wouldn't be sitting here would I be out
there running up and down why don't you
have a little bit of so this is so the
manager sits here the subs are here subs
and coaches lots of coaches have a
little and then and then when they're
playing they come out here and go nuts
well it's more expressive than others
but does Mr Emery go nuts was he a bit
calmer he's pretty expressive do you
ever go nuts what am I see
yeah I do
mainly when we score